this lecture today is going to be about
learning from legends and here we have a
legend Anatoly Karpov and I'm a
fantastic player I actually got to play
him in one game in 2007 and but I grew
up studying his games so I'm very
familiar with the style of play the type
of positions he played so very very
familiar with him with Karpov and
positionally was very strong always good
opening preparation but positionally
getting those small advantages and you
know converting them but today we
probably going to look at games where he
didn't just play so much position
basically he got great positions out of
the opening and quickly defeated them
strong players he defeated very quickly
masterpieces 22 moves 20 moves wins
so in this game he's he's playing a
grandmaster named unsecured very strong
new german grandmaster and this game is
played in 1975 Karpov in seeker so e4 e5
Karpov played both it's interesting the
first camp you see that he plays efore
but he also played d4 that it was so the
second game you're going to see it was a
default so Knight f3 knight c6 we should
be v eh6 so we see the classical real
offensive and white has couple of
options here SH take on c6 to play their
exchange violation but Bishop a4 is what
Karpov usually played this is the most
principled remove Knight f6 castles
Bishop e7 i would probably say this is
the probably the most popular position
so if you do some research in the chest
base or some other promise you'll see
that this is probably the most common
position in chess because it's just very
popular rook e1 b5 all theory d6 when
black plays d6 he is creating a threat
not a threat of winning material
he's creating a positional threat here
and the next move is almost forced here
for white what threat
did he just create by playing d6 you
camp in the night that's a possibility
but that's not very you camp in the
night ended h3 so it's pretty good but
something else you can do something
stronger here if let's say you would
play this move h3 now black will be
maybe slightly better already
correct
so the threat here is so lettuce Knight
a5 because he has protected already the
pawn on e5 so he wants to go Knight a5
and simply pick up the bishop and you
give them to bishops that's going to be
an advantage for black so you have to be
very careful not to lose your life's
commission which in fact logical bishop
is a very very strong piece here for you
so you don't want to lose it so that's
why when a d6 is played he can't see he
cannot play this move here because that
will blunder a central pawn so that's
why they when you play d6 the idea is 95
and Karpov play C 3 so if Knight a5 is
played he can tuck in the bishop on c2
so he's not losing the bishop castle and
now Bishop g4 in some positions might be
a little bit annoying so that's why it's
good for you to play h3 not only you
start Bishop g4 this is called a
multi-purpose move here you stop Knight
to g4 jumps Bishop g4 as I mentioned
already and also you create yourself
looped for the King that you may not
think it's necessary now but some point
you would
need that you know if things get
complicated there's some force
variations and you'll have a lift at the
end of the line you might get background
check made it and many games lost like
that even grandmaster games were just
they didn't create a lift and things got
a little bit complicated forced and he
just didn't have time he did not have
time to do it so it was night
a5 attacking the bishop so the move is
clear bishop see - he played c5 and here
for a moment if you look at it it looked
like Bach is doing great I mean he's got
all these pawns advanced and his castle
what is really white doing here
okay so there but here you start this is
still theory so white plays the move d4
idea behind this move is to open up his
dark square bishop and apply pressure on
c5 and e5 okay
putting more pressure now he plays Queen
c7
nice Billy - the problem in a black
position here this night is on the rim
so there are two different plants in
this position one plant is Knight a5 c5
and what is the other plum that is very
common in this position the one is the
one that once secured did but later on
he will regret that because he didn't
play very well and got a bit position
what's the other plum black normally
does here because blood needs to play
here the move c5 so his knight on c6 is
actually missed placed here so the other
planets here well that's the one we did
that one already the other one the other
plum here 95 is that's what unsecured it
but these didn't go very well here right
absolutely the other plant is Knight b8
and night goes to d7 I like this one a
little bit better because I don't like
to put that night on the rim you still
it's it takes the next see the
difference here you wasting some time in
the previous line you make a move he
responds so it's it's natural it feels
like we should play the first one
because you gaining temples but you can
also play like this both of them are
playable but this is different setup
then you go B should be 7 ok this is
another idea and the knight is this a
good nice like this D 7 in general when
your Knights are developed like this
they're pretty good because they're
protecting each other so so that's the
second plan here Knight a5 so this is
still theory Knight BD 2 Bishop d7 and
the next book is a very typical move for
this position because what are you going
to do with the 90s it's blocking your
Bishop and you're sort of aiming for an
attack in this position so you want to
bring more pieces if you're trying to
attack somebody you should try to bring
more pieces towards his King so when you
start the attack you have more power in
that area and a Karpov plays Knight f1
and now one secure makes a move that you
probably regret it because in this
position usually block takes takes and
play something like
rook fc8 and they even play Bishop b1 so
it's a playable position maybe slightly
better for white but one seeker didn't
realize the moment you don't really see
probably what is Karpov really trying to
do here so play the move rook e8 and now
very strong move by Karpov because here
he is playing against at night in the
corner he doesn't want that night to
come back and he wants to kind of try to
keep the position closed so he will have
good attacking chances yes absolutely d5
very strong move here and now we know
it's going to be a closed position with
Black Knight on the rim and look at the
attacking prospects even a bishop here
possibly there are quite a few pieces
aiming towards the black ink they're not
they're not looking very threatening at
the moment but slowly you will see how
carpel will build up here okay so now
ninety seven block is trying to find a
way to improve the position of the night
so now what would be the idea here for
black to improve the position yes
yes black wants to play c4 but what is
white should do here how should he try
to play against this move
he played Nightwing f3 to h2 the reason
because in these positions you want to
put the Queen on f3 and then you want to
go night g3 and also that gives you the
possibility to play f4 as well ok so he
waited on the 93 is coming up g6 trying
to a little bit control some squares but
that's a little bit weakening the dark
squares as well here so now yes you
could go Bishop h6 but you know he will
play something like Bishop f8 so better
to continue with the plan night goes on
g3 activating the night now he plays c4
black is hoping to get the knight in and
try to have some contra play but now
Karpov attacks yeah whenever he had an
opportunity positional Leo's extremely
strong carbo but whenever he had an
opportunity he wouldn't mind to take
some chances and go for an attack f4
takes on a fourth
Bishop f4 bishop f8 black is trying just
to defend here but the problem is the F
file now his King is going to find
himself in real trouble on that F file
here how do we attack him now on that F
file because we can put we can apply a
lot of pressure there as well the Bishop
g5 first and I don't know if you notice
but the knight doesn't have many squares
to go to and now he's ready to walk win
f3 next he just questioned the knight
here back no chance for long seeker has
to go back and now Queen d2 because if
you play Queen f3 what are you missing
tactics what's the tactic in this kind
of position here typical tactic more
hands more hands should be
efore
or
there you go there you go typical tactic
if the bishop who is putting pressure is
unprotected there is this tactic Knight
takes d5 if takes Bishop takes d5 okay
and if it goes Bishop e7 then you just
go back 97 so he can have that threat
because if he had gone Bishop g7 he
didn't have that threat because there is
no pressure here and after Queen f3 it's
going to be very difficult because the
knight has no squares to go to he
actually sort of gained time by playing
Bishop e7 now after Queen after you can
really protect the knight I mean Knight
h5 will be terrible takes and if Queen
d8 is just simply gonna revoke a finally
lose the knight so he plays Bishop here
Queen d2 now do we see why he played
that move he protected his Bishop so
when he starts putting pressure on AFR
the bishop is protecting no tactics
magnify will occur anymore that's by
protecting the loose piece whenever you
have a loose piece there could be some
potential tactics you have to protect
the loose piece Queen d4 you mean 2424
he doesn't want to do it because it
doesn't want to go to endgame when you
have strong attacking chances you don't
want to go to endgame so Queen d2 you
have a question Wow take your pin
remember I pinned you so that means
you're no longer attacking anything
because you pinned when the piece is
pinned it loses its power
remember everybody you may think it's
attacking something but don't forget if
it's pinned it cannot move I mean
especially if it's pinned to the king
absolute pin so Queen d2 Bishop c8 it's
it's not a good news if you have to play
a move like Bishop see it here but what
to do how to stop simple rook f1 or
Queen f4 ideas just too much pressure
here this is a position where it's not
just not defendable anymore so Bishop
went back to see it and now apply
pressure look F 1 by Karpov and the move
after which actually black resigned and
it may seem like a premature resignation
but in fact we'll take a look at the
position you will see that he just
didn't have any good ways to continue
fighting here move after which unsecured
resigned
he wants to put a knight only five and
that's going to be a good piece for him
so what can you do against that Knight
g4 absolutely correct the dread is
Knight h6 check try this Knight h6 check
very uncomfortable check and pick up on
f7 and if it goes 95 what do you do
don't rush because you might have a
better move here when you see a good
move look for a better one remember a
manual last cache take you have a big
advantage you might have something more
here yes absolutely correct has to take
because rook is on pre-finish six
checkmate on g7 so the only way he can
try to get you out of there is to go
back on d7 now what do you do
I actually want to suggest a spectacular
idea 9 h5 this didn't happen but this is
just we're analyzing further down the
point is now if it takes check checkmate
you can never survive when your king is
exposed like this and your pieces are
not around it and then you want to go
Queen h6 and checkmate here and if he
takes on f6 Knight takes f6 and you pick
up here okay
so Bishop f6 and Queen goes on h6
of
when so
and captures
because King AJ I think checkmate will
be quicker now unstoppable checkmate in
fact you can't do anything so yeah you
gotta look for this kind of knowledge
fire moves because if you don't find ih5
the game is going to go on a little bit
here because it's going to take a bishop
he's going to try to come up with some
defense now that's easy
now the h5 will finish them off because
then you've got Queen h6 coming up and
Queen g7
okay so nice g4
so what are the other alternatives here
the only thing else I can see here if
you can do is maybe to try to play King
g7 and now can you find the neat finish
here pitch pitch checks it goes back
2495 blocks it a little bit interesting
but do we have main okay well let's
let's start up with this first we should
take c7 the X is seven let's get our
queen in right check it goes here and
now my tribe still threatening checkmate
if you place f6 you go check so it has
to take back with a pawn and when he
takes back with a pawn your other piece
now is going to join the attack pushed
upon usually when you get one more
attacker in a position like this when
the King is exposed it will be
completely over he takes check checkmate
so it's only way not to get made it is
to play f5 but here you can play almost
anything wins here's where you can play
a poisson for example look f7
you can take on a drive night h6 check
picking up the rook so can't really do
anything
so that was one idea uh sugar probably
other ways to win here rook to except
five look at five and look to five as
well this kind of positions are not
defendable that's what I'm trying to say
you know if you know you could easily go
for like position like this if you look
at it if he has like one defender and
you have four or five pieces attacking
and his King is exposed with lots of
holes so he's going to have no chances
to win so that's why after ninety four
he resigns there was a nice quick win
quick win by it's a quick win by Karpov
here okay yeah yeah basically I can I I
think we can claim that one move like
rook e8 just cost him the game here
because after d5 is just basically White
has a free attack and yeah black could
have mini played a little bit better but
it's just such an unpleasant position
because you have absolutely no counter
play your pawns are not doing anything
on a queen side and he is just simply
attacking with a knight h2o Queen f3 93
he's just coming at you it's very
difficult to defend a position like this
because when you don't have any control
play and he is just activating all the
pieces and you're sitting there and I
think this just six was a poor move as
well it really weakened the position so
you normally don't want to push the pass
in front of the King when you're about
to be under attack but a position is
unpleasant I would I wouldn't want to
play this position at all like you know
it's black very unpleasant because no
concha play so which move he had to play
here to get some counter play he had to
capture and play something this kind of
nature maybe who Casey but something
like this is just still you know
playable I think in fact this could be a
theory so this we saw on this one we saw
an e4 play by Karpov what he just
demonstrated how he can play he for the
net
scam he's playing a very strong player a
world-class Grandmaster Alexander
Belyaev ski but less he is still playing
actively actually and it was just a very
strong player playing some candidate
tournaments but he didn't get a chance I
think to play for the world championship
match yet so subway lastly Karpov 1994
Linares super tournament Linares d4
Knight f6
now in this game we see him playing D
for almost 20 years later d4 Knight f3
d5 c4 e6 g3 what is the name of this
opening that white is trying to play
here yes
Catalan yes this Catalan was very
popular about three four years ago very
very popular became popular did a lot of
books written on it and just it was the
trend nowadays it's not as popular
because I think black figured out how I
can sort of try to neutralize it but
very popular at that time
so 1994 he tried this at that time it
wasn't very popular Bishop e7 Bishop e2
Castle and ticks and here when they take
your part you have basically two options
here as white one is to play Queen to c2
which he did to try to pick up the palm
back another option is to try to go 95
and take it with a knight but in fact
when you play 95 the strongest
theoretical response is strangely enough
96 the move that looks like wait a
minute how can you really do that here
but yeah this will actually equalize it
because takes takes
take it's possible to play a move like
this basic set that's one idea to
sacrifice in exchange you don't have to
do this or you can just play the move to
create in fact black is black is ahead
in development and white it's going to
have a hard time to coordinate his
pieces here even though the pawn
structure looks looks weaker for black
but you're just behind in development to
actually take advantage of that
structure so you'll have a hard time
consolidating your pieces and that B
file is going to be working well for
black because you'll be putting pressure
will be too so Queen c2 a6
a four
Bishop d7 idea behind a success he wants
to play b5 and this is actually a very
theoretical line here b5 Quincy to be
should be 752 this is big theory here
okay but what Karpov is trying to do he
is saying I don't want to allow b5 by
playing a for he's not allowing the move
p5 because if you play b5 that is just
going to be a blunder text you pick up
that rock okay so it goes Bishop d7
Quinn takes e4 Bishop c6
activating the Bishop Bishop g5 white is
developing his bishop and hoping to
complete the development and someday to
play the movie for when it's not under
attack so that way he can have the
control of the center we should be v
attacking the Queen Queen goes on d3
c5 Knight c3 developing developing is
very important you don't want to do
anything else but develop pieces and
here the lap ski makes a positional
mistake and it's a big problem because
your block you make a positional mistake
it's going to be very tough against
Karpov in Catalan it's very important
for you not to lose your light square
bishop if you lose your light square
bishop for the equal trade or something
you may not feel immediately the problem
but if you don't have a bishop opposing
this bishop here you're going to be in
trouble there are going to be serious
problems here
so here belowski clearly should have
played the move Bishop c6 this was
absolute master a little bit surprised
because positionally very strong played
belowski he made this inaccuracy takes
takes he was probably afraid of this but
there is 97 and 95 tactic that equalizes
the game the reason this tactic works
because after capture you can exchange
Queens to pick up the unprotected knight
on c3 so he perhaps miss that and if LT
is just going to be worse in
uncomfortable position
so he took C takes D for
and now what is the move here
Knight takes
Knight takes d5 absolutely picking up
the bishop absolutely you want to pick
up the bishop Knight takes d5 correct
okay
now you play Queen takes d5 and perhaps
you was thinking I will get my knight on
c6 you know and it's not going to be
that bad but I think he perhaps
overlooked
Karpov next move very powerful response
from Anatoly Karpov
what is the move here assume this and
move you can miss I am pretty sure this
is what he missed Queen Bishop is
hanging here
so if you take with the Queen he will go
96 and it's getting comfortable position
Kings
you can but the problem is what do you
have well piece is a piece here you're
losing a piece now that's a problem
h4 what's the idea behind our move
h4 explain the move - what's the idea
besides that what else now okay
good so he wants to take the pawn as
threat number one okay but there is
something else behind it he plays the
move Knight bd7 why why can't I just go
96 and claim that I have an extra pawn
here do you see what Karpov has in mind
had in mind here yes
see that then see how deep that moon was
on h4 this is what he missed this
sequence now he goes here you attack he
goes away you capture he takes checkmate
and if he eliminates your Bishop no
problem
you come back and you picking it up
again that Bishop any questions
take care and create problems
okay
so he played night bd7 question mark
actually there was a way for him oh so I
guess he could have losses without the
resistance yeah yeah so he paid 9b d7
and now natural move yes absolutely
night XT for attacking the Queen Queen
goes on d6
now do we want to take that punim b7
here
do we want to do that
well it looks like a free pawn maybe we
can take it but do you see the problem
behind it what is he going to do he's
going to for q95 porking and guess what
he's turning the tables on you and he is
actually maybe winning now because your
knife is loose see from a big advantage
one bad move you are in trouble suddenly
so the move here is natural mushroom
will get you a piece into the game
pieces not developing it it in and when
you move your queen now it's going to be
an x-ray on his Quinn so you have the
advantage you have the pressure
he goes 95
Quincy for moving away and now ready to
go discover the attack on that Queen
rook F d8 and now
if you move the night he wants to
sacrifice on d1 and get to puns
he gets it gets re he gets to two rooks
it gets two rooks for a queen
let's push that night away huh see what
is he going to do
if night he took here if he goes here
it's a very effective finish 96 because
he blocked the rock anymore so and then
you win the queen or the winner material
if you go night fe4 he just takes now
your night is hanging so you take back
he takes and winning couple of points
and again so you played here and now the
move after which now I think just a
couple of more moves you design now that
night is misplaced it's on the rim we
cannot take it because then he has this
b5 fork
okay so you have to do something first
against it
can we protect this rook and also attack
the knight at the same time protecting
the rook right three times now now you
can move he can't just move the knight
back anymore because that runs into the
same problem because he can no longer
sacrifice here we have a rule already
protecting it
okay so Queen b6 III accurate move
simply protecting the knight and now
still threatening to pick up the night
guess what that was the last move of the
game now master bailiffs ki resigned
because his Knight is trapped on the
ramp
no moves to go back if you go back he
just simply takes it so you cannot
really do anything the knight on the rim
is trapped
any questions
can't go to c3 cannot do anything you
pick up he takes he takes hey pick up
the knight little bit more complex game
it wasn't as crystal clear as the first
game but we saw how Karpov calculated
precisely and the highlight of the game
of course is this move here
h4 this is not an easy move to see
because he is anticipating what's going
to happen in couple of more moves and is
playing h4 to protect his bishop and
that gives him more possibilities with
the tactical ideas like 95 it was a very
strong display because the opponent he
played you can look him up Aleksandr
borovsky he is a very strong world-class
Grandmaster and at that time it was you
know basically almost a prime you know
of his career it right now he's much
much older so he's still playing really
well but at the moment 94 be left you
would you know very high ranking and
very strong player but positionally
super player but to see how cup of
defeat him like this 20 moves you're not
going to find too many games like this
lost by him so world-class player but
Karpov just played excellent game and I
think the mistake here was that we see
again when you make one mistake against
a very strong players basically they're
not going to let you come back in a game
and here we see the mistake was allowing
him to take that Bishop on d5 so you
should have played the move Bishop c6
the position would have been solid for
black but he took allowed Knight takes
d5 and after that after the strong h4
display there were no chances no chances
to get back into the game and he cannot
so this is a Karpov Belyaev skinned 1994
you can look at that game we can find on
the Internet